tenemos esta situación en donde hay un
contenedor de 4 metros cúbicos puede ser
un globo y que en lugar de tener
moléculas de un solo gas tenemos una
mezcla de tres gases diferentes
moléculas de oxígeno moléculas de
hidrógeno y moléculas de nitrógeno el
problema nos dice que tenemos 2.1
kilogramos en total del gas donde el
30.48 por ciento de la masa es oxigeno
2.86 son moléculas de hidrógeno y el 66
punto 67 por ciento es nitrógeno estamos
a condiciones normales de temperatura
cero grados celsius
es decir 273 kelvin y tenemos que
calcular cuál es la presión total que se
ejerce en el interior del contenedor y
aquí entra un nuevo concepto presión
parcial
necesitamos saber la presión parcial de
cada gas para saber qué tanto
contribuyen a la presión total si pueden
imaginar este contenedor con tres tipos
de gas es parte de la presión vendrá del
gas azul que puede ser el oxígeno
chocando contra las paredes otra parte
vendrá del hidrógeno que puede ser el
amarillo y otra parte de la presión
vendrá del nitrógeno golpeando las
paredes el naranja
entonces la presión parcial por ejemplo
del nitrógeno corresponde a las
moléculas naranjas que chocan contra las
paredes vamos a ver lo primero que
podemos hacer para llegar a calcular la
presión total es el número total de
moléculas que tenemos así podemos saber
cuántos moles tenemos por cada molécula
de gas
así que 2.1 kilogramos de gas lo iré
escribiendo
si queremos saber cuántos moles de
nitrógeno hay
moles del nitrógeno
sabemos que el 66 punto 67 por ciento de
esta mezcla corresponde al nitrógeno
entonces pasando la masa gramos porque
cuando hablamos de masa molecular
siempre se expresan en gramos este
porcentaje equivale a los dos tercios de
2.100 esto es igual a 1.400 gramos de n
2.400 gramos
cuál es la masa molar del nitrógeno
molecular bueno sabemos que la masa
atómica del nitrógeno es 14 como la
molécula tiene 2 nitrógenos entonces su
masa atómica es de 28 es decir un molde
n 2 es igual a 28 gramos un mol
n 2 es igual a 28 gramos sobre mol
nosotros tenemos 1.400 gramos entonces
tenemos perdón aquí son gramos por mol
hay que tener bien las unidades 1.400
gramos entre 28 gramos por mol es igual
vamos a ver
1400 entre 28 es igual a 50 tenemos
50 moles de n 2
50 moles
ok ahora hagamos el mismo procedimiento
para el caso del oxígeno en el oxígeno
tenemos alrededor del 30 por ciento para
el oxígeno tenemos recuerden estos
porcentajes corresponden a la masa total
no a los moles esos son los que nosotros
estamos calculando entonces 30.48 por
ciento de 2.100 gramos es igual
a punto 30 48 x 2100 es igual a 640.000
gramos y cuál es la masa de un molde
oxígeno molecular sabemos que la masa
atómica del oxígeno es de 16 lo pueden
verificar con una tabla periódica aunque
tal vez ya estén familiarizados entonces
la masa molecular de dos moléculas de
hidrógeno es de 32 unidades atómicas un
molde de o2 es igual a 32 gramos
tenemos 640 gramos cuántos moles serán
640 entre 32 es igual a 20 20 moles de
oxígeno
20 moles
ahora calculemos los del hidrógeno 2 86%
de todo esto es hidrógeno tenemos 2 mil
100 gramos
recuerden convertir la masa gramos 2 mil
100 gramos por
cuando era punto 0 286 es igual a 60
puntos 0 6 gramos
entonces hidrógeno el 2% es igual a 60
gramos y cuál es la masa molar del
hidrógeno molecular sabemos que la masa
de un solo átomo de hidrógeno ese 1 como
son 2 su masa es de 2 gramos entonces un
molde h 2
vamos a notar lo aquí abajito un molde
de h2 es igual a 2 gramos
nosotros tenemos 60 gramos 60 entre 2
son 30 moles
30 moles
esto es muy interesante aún cuando el
hidrógeno está presente en una fracción
muy pequeña de la masa total del gas
dentro del contenedor resultaron más
partículas más moléculas de hidrógeno de
las que tenemos de oxígeno esto es
porque una molécula de h2 pesa sólo 2
gramos mientras que una de 2 pesa 32
gramos entonces ya nos dimos cuenta de
que tenemos más partículas de hidrógeno
que de oxígeno en el contenedor y las
partículas es lo que importan por eso lo
primero que calculamos fue cuántas
partículas tenemos dentro del contenedor
20 moles de oxígeno 30 moles de
hidrógeno 50 moles de nitrógeno en total
tenemos 100 moles del gas si queremos
saber cuál es la presión total primero
podemos simplemente aplicar los 100
moles déjenme borrar esto
dejaré que se pueda ver esta parte del
problema
sabemos que bebé es igual a nrc y
queremos calcular p
p por 4 metros cúbicos
es igual a n n es el número de moles
tenemos 100 moles
por ere dejaré un espacio ahorita vemos
que rehusar por la temperatura recuerden
debe estar en kelvin entonces 0 grados
celsius
son 273 kelvin y que erre usaremos abajo
tengo los valores si estamos trabajando
con metros cúbicos y no en litros usamos
esta 8.3 145 metro cúbico pascal por mol
kelvin
8.3 145 y las unidades
y las hay verdad perdón
las unidades están en metro cúbico
pascal entre mol
kelvin y la temperatura era de 273
kelvin hagamos nuestro análisis
dimensional para asegurarnos de que
estén bien las unidades estos metros
cúbicos se cancelan con estos y también
los moles se cancelan
kervin en el numerador se cancela con el
denominador y al final solo me quedan
pascal es lo cual está bien porque
queremos unidades de presión entonces si
dividimos ambos lados de la ecuación
entre 4 tenemos que p es igual a 25 por
8.30 y 145 por 273 y sabemos que nos
quedará en pascal es usemos la
calculadora 25 x 8.31 45 por 273 es
igual a 56 mil 746 56.746 pascales
parece un número muy exagerado pero en
realidad no es así
porque 101 mil 325 pascales son igual
a una atmósfera una atmósfera para saber
cuántas atmósferas es esto dividimos lo
que nos salió entre 101 mil dejen de
verificar que esto esté bien así
convertir esto aquí lo pascal es esto es
56.746 kilopascales o si lo quieren en
atmósferas
56 746 entre 10 y 13 25 es igual a punto
56.56 atmósferas esa es la presión total
que se está ejerciendo entre todos los
gases ahora mi pregunta es cuál es la
presión parcial
podemos usar cualquiera de estos números
sólo cambian las unidades cuál es la
presión parcial por ejemplo del oxígeno
bueno hay que fijarnos en los moles ya
no nos interesa la masa porque estamos
suponiendo que son gases ideales nos
fijamos en el número de partículas
porque recuerden que dijimos que la
presión por volumen es igual al número
de partículas por la temperatura y todos
están a la misma temperatura
lo que importa es el número de
partículas entonces la presión parcial
del oxígeno es igual al 20 por ciento de
las partículas totales entonces la
presión parcial es igual al 20% por
algún dato de la presión que puede ser
en kilopascales o en atmósferas aquí yo
ya lo tengo en gilo pascales pero usaré
atmósferas entonces punto 56 es que ya
tenemos por punto 20 eso es igual a
punto 112 atmósferas punto 112
atmósferas
qué es el 20 por ciento de esto como
supe que el 20 por ciento bueno porque
en total tenemos 100 moles de la mezcla
gaseosa y el 20 por ciento de esos son
de oxígeno equivale al 20 por ciento
entonces el 20 por ciento de la presión
es la que ejerce el oxígeno son los sacó
el 20 por ciento de cualquiera de estos
números y va a cambiar dependiendo de
las unidades si por ejemplo yo quiero
esta cantidad pero en kilopascales es
igual a 11.2 kilopascales hagamos el
mismo procedimiento para el nitrógeno
cuál es la presión parcial del nitrógeno
aún cuando el 66 por ciento de la masa
gaseosa es nitrógeno solo el 50 por
ciento de las partículas totales
pertenecen al nitrógeno entonces 50 por
ciento de la presión total nos dará la
presión que ejercen las partículas de
nitrógeno en el recipiente la presión
parcial del nitrógeno es igual al 50 por
ciento de esto es aproximadamente de
28.000
373 pascal es o es también
aproximadamente
28.4 kilopascales o aproximadamente
punto 28 atmósferas
y finalmente para saber la presión
parcial del hidrógeno lo pondré en otro
color el hidrógeno aún cuando es una
cantidad pequeña de masa representa el
30 por ciento de las moléculas totales
de las moléculas que aplican presión al
contenedor entonces 30 por ciento de las
moléculas de hidrógeno 30 por ciento de
las moléculas recuerden si hablamos de
energía cinética la masa se mueve
dependiendo de la temperatura de la
energía promedio entonces podemos
imaginar que el hidrógeno se mueve más
rápido a comparación del oxígeno o el
nitrógeno aunque no tenemos que pensar
mucho en eso ahora tenemos que la
presión parcial del hidrógeno es igual
al 30 por ciento de cualquiera de estos
valores elegimos punto 56 atmósferas
punto 3 por punto 56 es igual a punto
168 atmósferas entonces la presión total
es igual o debe ser igual a la suma de
todas las presiones parciales
el nitrógeno más la presión del oxígeno
más la presión parcial del hidrógeno si
sumamos todo esto que es punto 28
atmósferas más lacio el oxígeno que eran
puntos 112 atmósferas más este que es
punto 168 si sumamos todo esto verán que
es igual a punto 56 atmósferas es decir
la presión total del sistema este fue un
problema largo pero lo más importante
recordar es que cada molécula del
sistema contribuye a la presión total en
la proporción al número de moles que
tiene según el porcentaje en el que está
presente en el sistema espero no sea muy
confuso